in this video I want to talk about
signal transduction and the sort of
general idea behind it and how it works
so when we think about signal
transduction we're thinking about
specifically a specific type of signal
and that signal is going to be a polar
signal and the reason why is because
when we think about signal transduction
the signal that's going to bind the
receptor of a cell is going to be a
polar signal and because of this polar
that means it's going to bind a receptor
on the cell surface so the receptor is
on the outside of the cell so if this
here is a signal let's just call it
specifically the hormone because that's
what we're going to be using or thinking
about in future videos a hormone is
going to come on over and bind a
particular receptor protein that is
embedded in the plasma membrane of a
cell so the plasma membrane of course
has a hydrophobic interior right and the
extracellular space which is the outside
of the cell and the intracellular space
the space bound within the cell are both
going to be hydrophilic oops
hydrophilic so this hormone if it's
polar it's going to want to stay in that
hydrophilic area so this hormone is
going to come on over and bind this
receptor protein and it will fit nice
and snug and that happens there's a
conformational change in this receptor
protein and that will usually trigger a
series of reactions that's that's what
this these arrow is sort of represent
here is the series of reactions or a
series of steps now though a series of
steps or reactions what they do is they
produce second messengers
and it produces tons of them and that's
what part of the reason I have so many
of these arrows here so I right here I
wrote here why so many arrows here what
am I getting at I'm getting at obviously
the fact that there's a bunch of these
second messengers that are created and
more specifically I'm getting at the
fact that large amount of second
messengers amplifies a signal so there's
this amplification of the signal one
hormone binding event creates many
second messengers now what are these
second messengers do they activate some
sort of cell response they change things
in the cell whatever that may be
now usually what that happens it has it
causes changes in activity of cellular
enzymes via covalent modification
specifically phosphorylation of
particular enzymes now well
phosphorylating a protein increase or
decrease the enzymes activity now a lot
of people instinctively will want to say
increase and a lot of the times they'd
be right but it really does depend so it
depends what does it depend on well if
you think back to when we talked about
protein structure and covalent
modification then you have to remember
that phosphorylating a protein or
phosphorylated protein specifically on
its gonna happen on a specific amino
acid residue right a serine tyrosine or
a threonine now when that happens you're
changing the protein structure when you
change a protein structure you're
changing its function now adding a
phosphate doesn't necessarily mean that
it's going to change it into a structure
change the structure into a more active
state that could be the case but it's
not necessarily the case so it can
phosphorylation can increase or can
decrease enzyme activity it depends okay
it depends on the enzyme that's being
phosphorylated okay so be aware of that
just because something's being
phosphorylated does not mean it'll
increase its active
depends on the enzyme hope that video
was a good little overview what's going
on with signal transduction one last
thing I'm a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email Mufi university at
gmail.com and see the description below
from our details thanks for watching